♪ ♪ ♪
- Imaginez : confronté
à la tragédie, pouvoir remonter
dans le temps afin d'éviter
le pire. C'est la prémisse
de la série "Plan B".
- Mylène Clairmont?
- Dans cette troisième saison,
une policière tourmentée,
incarnée par Anne-Élizabeth
Bossé, a recours aux services
de l'agence Plan B pour tenter
d'éviter qu'un homme tue
sa femme et ses deux enfants.
ANNE-ÉLISABETH BOSSÉ, comédienne
- C'est une héroïne
très imparfaite,
extrêmement désobéissante,
très en colère, aussi.
Des fois, on a de la difficulté
avec les personnages féminins
colériques, mais je pense
que dans ce cas-ci, c'est ça
que ça soulève, ces drames-là :
de la colère, de l'indignation.
- Un sujet tristement
d'actualité, alors qu'au Québec
cette année seulement, 17 femmes
ont été tuées par leur conjoint.
Le couple est incarné par
Vincent Leclerc et Mélanie
Pilon, qui partagent leur vie
à la ville comme à l'écran.
VINCENT LECLERC, comédien
- C'était dense, c'était
douloureux. J'en suis sorti,
je crois, pour la première fois,
un peu... un peu meurtri,
de... de ce voyage-là.
Je m'en remets encore!
- Il est arrivé
quelque chose à Bruno?
MÉLANIE PILON, comédienne
- La violence, elle s'installe,
elle s'immisce tranquillement,
on s'en rend pas compte.
On est beaucoup au niveau
psychologique au début,
puis tranquillement, on isole
la femme de son entourage.
Tu perds tes repères,
ton estime de toi est à zéro,
donc tu ne réussis plus à savoir
comment t'en sortir, en fait.
Je voulais pas lui enlever
les filles. Je voulais juste
que ça arrête.
- La série poignante s'intéresse
aux motivations du tueur et
aux conséquences lourdes pour
l'entourage et pour ceux qui
n'ont pas pu prévenir le pire.
- Là où c'est très délicat,
c'est qu'on humanise tous
les personnages, pas seulement
les victimes. C'est qu'on entre
dans la tête de tout le monde,
puis on essaie de comprendre
pourquoi ces choses-là arrivent,
sont-elles évitables?
♪ ♪ ♪
- Comme dans les deux saisons
précédentes de "Plan B",
ces voyages temporels ne
produiront pas les effets
escomptés. Pas facile
de jouer avec le destin.
- Je pense qu'on a tous
en nous le désir de vouloir
aller changer des choses dans
le passé, fait que ça a ça de
fédérateur, ça a ça de curieux.
Puis, comme c'est pas traité
comme de la science-fiction,
c'est vraiment traité comme
un drame psychologique,
je pense que toutes
ces choses-là ensemble
font qu'on a envie d'embarquer
pour un troisième voyage.
- Il y a quelque chose qui peut
être un baume dans cette série-
là, qui peut être salvateur
et qui soulève des questions
vraiment pas évidentes,
mais très nécessaires.
♪ ♪ ♪
- "Plan B" sera diffusé à
compter de mercredi sur ICI Télé
et en primeur dans la section
Véro.tv d'ICI Tou.tv.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- Fait que je l'ai-tu fait comme
il faut, ma job, oui ou non?
- Tout va bien?
- Oui!